[Music]
for the
you need to register you need a license
plate for us
thing and everything i can use the bike
for the door guys i'm picking up a
delivery
yeah it's a 49 cc though it doesn't
matter if you're keeping it on the road
you have to have it registered with new
york state you have any paperwork for it
at all yes i do i can show you right now
yes i can show you right now i can't see
your license
ticket for the
then you're going to get in trouble for
not taking it
probably
yeah but you walked away right yeah yeah
you walked away and then you came back
keep bothering her and she's like
as well
why i don't i don't understand i'm doing
over each day i'm doing a job she has a
license
you were driving this thing yeah i was
driving too long
but i drive it too that is nothing to do
with she was driving so we need to
is
come on
[Music]
[Music]
i am
and you scared of black people
god
crazy
because my uncles
that's my first
put my head on my head
yes
um
wow
i don't have the license for the bike
stop harassing people
you got your glasses on
yes
she's wrong
is
[Music]
oh
you can't just come here